[Music]
in damn psycho news cycle / submitted by
love from New Mexico oh I love your
sunsets Santa Fe New Mexico orange
purple green not snot green it's it's
just colorful it's a cowboy orange the
same the whole sky lights up it's like
in all of my colors that's cause they're
pretty flat there yeah that's cool a 19
year old rape suspect reportedly bragged
about his victim dying while having sex
with him what brag about it was so
boring she died it's like my dick is so
big it kills her that was a girl right
poor guy
for what wait so it was who was the
victim victim was a girl
Oh other dude is that dude okay so it's
Brian 19 year old sexually assaulted
Alyssa
18 year olds Brian so story goes that
they were hanging out at his trailer
home in Washington would this picture
has painted really nice
it started in a trailer park Cleatus
with three teeth hair snorted percocets
[Music]
the park to prescription drugs and
apparently she just laid on his bed
they'd like to take medications in the
weirdest ways because percocet is pills
if you just swallowed it
yeah you don't have a seat stronger than
the the cannabis they could've just
smoked it but they have to do a liquid
version maybe it's more potent that's
like saying they injected heroin through
their anus yeah
are they put in their eyeball oh no they
do do that right what I do like acid
like that they just like to do things
the hard way it's just not a pleasant
way to get right that know what I've
heard that you get drunk through your
back yeah
but I want to get drunk through my butt
I like it
I heard you could easily have all
burning because your liver doesn't
process it yeah trying to give yourself
an alcohol animal I've been also um kind
of going crazy from edibles because your
it takes your body longer to process you
can overdose eating it so like yeah
they've been having like schizophrenic
episodes or it's unlocked dormant whole
even those got even gummy bears okay
disturbing story yeah so care about the
death rape I know this is so Brian he
was texting his friends like he texted a
photo of her as she laid unconscious he
said lol I think she Oded still
breathing and then so that was that
night right he left her apparently he
had sex with her to pass the time
oh she's out she's dead so if he doesn't
know he says I don't know if she was
alive when I ejaculated into her like I
came in her he so he's sleep [ __ ] her
he doesn't even know if she was alive
when he came in her so she was when she
was uh he's on drugs right uh true but
still that's [ __ ] I don't know I think
when someone's on not to say anything
bad like it's a pass but I'm just like
you're in a [ __ ] different place in
your mind no like this Bulls [ __ ]
[ __ ] up okay [ __ ] him even more yeah
because then after so he didn't bother
calling me paramedics at all oh what a
[ __ ] dick he ended up going to [ __ ]
it'll just what came out yo my [ __ ]
don't ever argue with somebody in the
street it's gonna be really bad for you
what's that you go [ __ ] [ __ ] dick
okay oh my god stupid I'm like did I
just say that so get do quino's sorry
this is the [ __ ] poopoo tooth okay
to food would see this cute in the best
that she giggles after I've ever done
that like even this part [ __ ] was
embarrassing anyway no you little
Japanese Mexican so it's like yeah so he
did not call the paramedics for help or
nothing instead he went to bed because
he was too tired to do anything else the
saber that she's in that's a good
question cuz they do mention that she
was is it was bad on a bed but I'm just
asking he slept next to her well they do
say that she was in the same bedroom as
he was I don't know where he slept I'd
be [ __ ] weird okay but yeah so then
he the next morning he woke up he used
her lifeless thumb to access her iPhone
posted on her snapchat something that
suggests that she ran away so no one
would be on her his tail and then he
washed her body to get rid of any DNA oh
so they can't link him to her death what
about the calm you [ __ ] idiot that's
why I was thinking like oh my god did he
wash all up in there to you so you
washed her dead body yes you what
instead of calling the cops or the
paramedics don't lie maybe he took it a
step further when he he broke her legs
so he can fit her plastic bin wasted
like this isn't well
sounds like he's done it before
something yeah and I thought you were
gonna say like after he [ __ ] her and
came all over and he gave her a shower
but he couldn't resist so he [ __ ] her
again her again he probably did yeah and
then yeah like he just [ __ ] her to
past the time oh just and then so anyway
he went to work started it like bragging
about it like oh yeah I was having sex
this garden even though she was still
alive and I was coming zombie
and that's actually good and then the
co-workers contact the police Mart and
oh he also took her phone and threw it
near the Dairy Queen where he was
working because he worked a double shift
that that next day why would he throw it
away somewhere so close to his workplace
exactly I stuck it in the saucer
machines and nobody would find this he's
[ __ ] narcissistic cuz he's just like
no one's that I'm this I'm that what do
you think his co-workers were gonna say
- by the way I was [ __ ] the dead
because I murdered her those crazy
narcissist dude oh he was like uh he was
probably gonna get a good job from his
hookers like a high five bro good job so
they caught him because they found the
phone so then they're saying that police
police move forward when they saw or
someone Oh a co-worker later spotted a
post on Facebook from the girl's mom
saying that the girl was missing and
police moved in on him since there were
all these other clues and they found her
lifeless body stuffed inside a black bin
and he said he admitted to police that
he was planning on burying her with
onions to mask the smell oh my god say
that info like he but he how did he even
know that oh maybe he likes searched
maybe why would you link criminals that
just spill the beans like that either
yeah it was it you well I was gonna bury
it with some onions hey all right buddy
you have the right to remain snow I'm
gonna tell you I was gonna [ __ ] him back
well [ __ ] when she was bad I know
that's [ __ ] weird he's a weirdo yeah
saying that he showed a callous and
shocking disregard for human life
oh he's insane set the bail at $500,000
anybody else want us Norfolk to stay
with me no I think these that this girl
died like at all
yeah at all another oh and he was taking
photo I mentioned this I think he was
taking photos and then sending him to
the friends like lol yeah the lol she
owed Edith was on that job what kind of
friends does he have if they accept this
guy well they're probably crazy Dairy
Queen is is that you were hire some
buddy like that Dairy Queen to
Washington prestigious establishment
yeah yeah there's the team up with
Orange Julius she asian no next to get
her she is cute yeah poor girl I did not
expect that he's small I thought he was
gonna be like a lot bigger psycho yeah
he's our kind of crazy 19 maybe that's
why he's so insecure and has to brag
about yeah that's probably why I had to
wager Alanis I think I will keep them in
my jail cell and then every month or so
we will take a small little part of a
finger and then another finger and
another finger and like it's just gonna
keep going down like this and then it's
gonna be slowly he's gonna see every
little part go away he'll go away he'll
go away and then he's gonna be nothing
but just like like chest and torso
that's all and then and then like I'm
gonna have a bunch of hungry apps that
come into the place and eat him every
day oh my god yeah you think about this
tepid
no I'm like was the worst thing I could
do to somebody the so interesting it's
so sad so he was taken into custody on
suspicion of manslaughter homicide by
control substance and second-degree rape
that's crazy
damn so I'm assuming I wonder what type
of home he grew up in I know cuz he just
like their dad body in his room while he
went to go work a double shift and was
it his trailer or his family's trailer
cuz uh that house didn't look like a
trailer at all oh the bathroom mm-hmm
sometimes I'm like like mobile home
mobile homes or just homes with wheels
yeah the living room rooms everything
yeah they're pretty damn big a house
thinking of a RV things like this is
like a so eerie because that could be me
overdosing in a bed when I was 18 that
could have been me you know and someone
[ __ ] your lifeless body yeah and it
not good hops or something if I
overdosed or whatever photos of your
body blue lips and everything to your
friend yeah that's really weird I was
surprised that the friends didn't call
the police like it took the co-worker to
I would I would put them in jail too
yeah they all [ __ ] weird yeah d-don't
percocets and weed oil yeah don't like
that maybe it's a lot of percocets yeah
some people are really sensitive to it
because I had a friend in high school
here and him and his girlfriend decided
to drop eat together and then she's like
a real tiny girl she was like 90 pounds
ish and I don't know if she had heart
problems or whatever but they rolled and
then in the middle of sex she died they
were yeah oh my god so and then he was
just okay what I have sex won't eat yeah
she died yeah she died yeah yeah yeah
probably giving in the process then the
process of trying to so she probably had
a deer didn't like because the sex is so
intense and then like they're already
rolling and he's rolling and lifeless
and yeah also yeah I've heard you can OD
the first time you do X because you
don't know how much your body can take
mmm some people can't take care off
don't do drugs
don't do drugs this girl could have been
saved possibly if she was at the library
and not up a drug house yeah but if you
were just called the paramedics you
didn't say oh yeah that's true instead
of [ __ ] her lifeless body
[Music]